MALE SPEAKER: Hello everyone.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I work on the Privacy Team.
Thanks for coming to this
Authors at Google Talk.
Let me tell you a little bit
about our guest of honor today.
Robert Sloan grew
up near Detroit
and likes to say
that he now splits
this time between San
Francisco and the internet.
He graduated from Michigan State
with a degree in economics.
And from 2002 to 2012, he
worked at Pointer, Current TV,
and Twitter.
At all these places
his job always
had something to do
with figuring out
the future of media.
The "New York Times" describes
his recent bestselling
hit "Mr. Penumbra's 24-Hour
Bookstore" as a rollicking
neo-Borgesian tale about an
unemployed San Francisco web
designer who takes a job
at a mysterious bookshop
only to find himself initiated
into the unbroken spine,
a 500-year-old secret
society of bibliophiles
on an unexpected collision
course with Google.
Please join me in welcoming
to Google Mr. Robin Sloan.
ROBIN SLOAN: Thank you.
It's good to be hear.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: So I
think today you're
hoping to kick us off a
little bit of a reading--
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: --some
choice bits from your book.
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And if
anybody has any questions,
I think we're going
to try to save those
to the end of the reading.
And you can use the mic here
in the middle of the room.
ROBIN SLOAN: OK.
Well thank you.
Thank you for the
kind introduction.
It's go good to be here.
For people who
have read the book,
you know that Google features
prominently into the plot.
And I've just finished
up a little book tour
to commemorate the
paperback release.
And I have to report that at
every stop across the country,
people always ask, is
Google really like that?
And I have to confess
that it's not really.
And I tell them, I do say that
the depiction in my novel,
my work of fiction,
is definitely not
intended to be like
documentary style.
I tell them, though, that is
an affectionate exaggeration.
And I hope it sounds
that way to you as well.
So since I'm here at
Google, and since I just
had lunch in one
of your many cafes,
I felt like I probably had to
read this very short section
in which our
narrator who's a web
designer-- an unemployed
web designer-- who
works at a mysterious
24-hour bookstore,
he goes to the Google campus--
the fictional Google campus--
for the first time
and he has lunch.
Wide walkways curve
through the main campus.
There's a bike lane
and Googlers whiz
by on carbon fiber racers and
fixed gears with battery packs.
There's a pair of gray
beards on recumbents
and a tall do dude with blue
dreadlocks pedaling a unicycle.
I reserved some time on
the book scanner at 12:30,
Kat says, lunch first?
The Google mess hall comes
into view, wide and low,
a white pavilion staked
out like a garden party.
The front is open, tarp
pulled up above the entryways,
and short lines of Googlers
poke out into the lawn.
Kat pauses, squinting,
calculating.
This one, she says finally, and
tugs me over to leftmost line.
I'm a pretty good
queue strategist,
but it's not easy here
because everyone at Google
is a queue
strategist, I suggest.
Exactly.
So sometimes there's bluffing.
Hey, this guy's a
bluffer, she says,
jabbing the Googler just ahead
of us in line with her elbow.
He's tall and sandy haired,
and he looks like a surfer.
Hey, I am Finn, he
says, holding out
a blocking long fingered hand.
Your first visit to Google?
It is, indeed, my
ambiguously European friend.
I make small talk.
How's the food?
Oh fantastic.
The chef is famous.
He pauses.
Something clicks.
Kat, he must use the other line.
Right, I always
forget, Kat says.
She explains our
food is personalized.
It has vitamins, some
natural stimulants.
Finn nods vigorously.
I am experimenting with
my potassium level.
Now I'm up to 11
bananas every day.
Body hacking.
His face splits
into a wide grin.
Wait.
Did the couscous
salad have stimulants?
Sorry, Kat says, frowning.
The visitor line is over there.
She points across the
lawn, and I leave her
with the body
hacking euro surfer.
The food is as
promised fantastic.
I get two scoops of lentil
salad and a thick pink stripe
of fish, seven sturdy
green lines of asparagus,
and a single
chocolate chip cookie
that has been optimized
for crispiness.
Kat waves me over to a table
near the pavilion's perimeter
where a quick breeze is
rustling the white tarp.
Little slices of light
dance across the table which
has a paper covering marked
out with a pale blue grid.
At Google, they eat
lunch on graph paper.
This is Raj, she says, waving a
fork full of lentil salad which
looks just like
mine, at a skater
Ph.D. We went to
school together.
Kat studied symbolic
systems at Stanford.
Did everybody here
go to Stanford?
Do they just give you a job
at Google when you graduate?
When Raj speaks,
he seemed suddenly
10 years older than
his appearance.
His voice is clipped and direct.
So what do you do?
I hoped that question would
be outlawed here, replaced
by some quirky Google
equivalent like, what's
your favorite prime number?
I point at my badge
and concede that I
work at a used bookstore,
in other words,
the opposite of Google.
Ah, books, Raj pauses
a moment chewing.
Then his brain
slots into a groove.
You know, old books
are a problem for us,
old knowledge in general.
We call it OK,
old knowledge, OK.
Did you know that
95% of the internet
was only created in
the last five years?
But we know that when it
comes to all human knowledge,
the ratio is just the opposite.
In fact, OK, [INAUDIBLE]
for most things
that most people know
and have ever known.
Raj is not blinking and
possibly not breathing.
So where is it, right?
Where's the OK?
Well it's in old
books for one thing.
He uncaps a thin tipped marker.
Where did that come from?
And starts drawing on the
graph paper tablecloth.
And it's also in people's heads,
a lot of traditional knowledge.
That's what we call TK.
OK and TK.
He's drawing little
overlapping blobs
labeling them with
these acronyms.
Imagine if we could make
all that OK TK available
all the time to everyone
on the web, on your phone?
No question would go
unanswered ever again.
I wonder what Raj
has in his lunch.
Vitamin D, omega 3's,
fermented tea leaves,
he says, still scribbling.
He makes a single dot off
to the side of the blobs
and smooshes the marker down
making the black ink bleed.
That's what we've
got stored right now,
he says, pointing to the dot.
And just think how
valuable that is.
If we get all this--
he sweeps his hand
across the OK TK blobs like
a general planning conquest--
well if we could
add all this, then
we could really get serious.
MALE SPEAKER: So I have to ask--
my first question would be,
who's your favorite character?
ROBIN SLOAN: My favorite
character in the book is Kat.
And so for folks who have
read the book, of course
you know who that is.
For folks who
haven't, I'll explain
that she is an engineer.
She's actually a Googler.
She's the one who invites
our protagonist to the campus
and sort of shows him around.
She's a designer.
She's into data
visualization, but she's also
a programmer in her own right.
And over the course
of the book, she
becomes more and
more of a manager.
And she's basically a bad ass.
And she's my favorite
character because I
used to work with Kat
or many versions of Kat.
And as I read everything,
contemporary fiction
and fiction of technology
in it, and techno thrillers,
and all the rest, I noticed
that Kat or this Kat archetype
was usually not
present in these books.
And more and more
I decided that I
wanted to do my tiny little
part to help remedy that.
So I both like her
as a character,
but I'm also proud
to have kind of put
that person on
the fiction shelf.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you
feel like your book
is sort of filling in
any other maybe things
that you felt were missing
from the literary landscape?
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, I'm someone
who-- I worked at Twitter
for a few years and have
always been fascinated
by the web and the internet.
And I mean, I really feel
like I sort of grew up
as both a reader and a
writer on the internet.
It's my native country, right?
I'm definitely a
citizen of the internet.
And kind of combining that
with all the experiences
that a person has
in the Bay Area,
knowing people who
work at Google, people
who work at Twitter, people
who have started companies
of their own, I think you end up
with a whole map of experiences
that are actually
really interesting.
And I would say largely absent
from contemporary fiction.
And whether that's just
because most writers live
somewhere else or because of the
old divide between left brain
and right brain or whatever
it is, the more I read,
the more I kind of just
sensed that the things that I
saw every day and thought
were really interesting
were like not on the pages
of the novels I was reading.
AUDIENCE: About
that a little bit,
how was your transition
from IT to being an author?
Are you a full-time right now?
And also when you're writing,
what's your day to day?
How does it look like?
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
Good question.
Well I was actually
explaining earlier,
so the Google office
is nice of course.
Twitter's office
was nice as well.
And I was happy to work
in such a nice office.
Actually, I've worked
at a bunch of companies
that were all wonderful
places to work.
And I feel like that was
helpful because I still
didn't like working
in those offices.
And I figured if I didn't
like those offices,
I wasn't going to
like any offices.
So I have found the
transition from-- it's
been less about tack
to writing and more
about working in an office
to working on your own.
And that's obviously
a temperamental thing.
Everyone's different.
But I have found that
totally copacetic.
But what it means is that
my day to day routine
is I think actually pretty
normal for a full-time writer.
I spend most of the
day alone sitting
at my kitchen table
just pecking away.
This might be
useful folks who are
thinking about this themselves
or maybe struggling with it,
I use a program that
is very popular--
increasingly popular-- among
writers called Freedom.
Anybody know this
program Freedom?
It's great.
It's free to try.
It does one thing.
You open up the
application, and it asks you
for a number of minutes.
And you type in-- in
my case I usually type
in about 120 minutes.
You hit Return and it disables
the internet on like a very--
[LAUGHTER]
ROBIN SLOAN: --on
like a very low level.
This is not turning
off your Wi-Fi.
If you want to turn
it back on, you
have to restart your
computer and just
feel like a failure in life.
So you don't.
So you just leave it
off until it returns.
And so my day is
mostly me undergoing
a sequence of internet
deactivations.
What am I going to do?
I guess I'll work on this book.
AUDIENCE: I am
fascinated by-- I'm
sort of the old school league.
You can tell by the gray hair.
It's because I'm old.
And I have many, many
younger friends here.
And I love books on paper.
I discover a lot of people don't
necessarily love books on paper
anymore.
They want them on their Kindle.
I probably have 4 or
5,000 books at home.
ROBIN SLOAN: Wow.
AUDIENCE: And I know some
people who have none.
They have their Kindle.
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you
speak a little bit
to the idea of the
importance of bookstores
since your book is about
a bookstore and that sort
of balance between
paper and online?
ROBIN SLOAN: That's
an awesome question.
Well, I will say one thing.
I think people who do one or
the other are relatively rare.
That is, people who
only have print books
and have never touched
a digital book,
and conversely, people who
have these entirely digital
libraries and have just
abandoned physical books
entirely.
Especially for people
who read a lot,
you find sort of a hybrid mode.
I think that's important.
People want to frame it
as one versus the other.
And in fact, people read lots
and lots of different contexts.
I think that's a good thing.
I will say that for me
personally the pendulum
has kind of swung
and then swung back,
of course, as digital
books became available,
I read more on Kindles and
phones and my laptop screen
and everything.
In the last couple years,
it started to swing back.
I never gave up physical books.
But it started to
swing back, and I
find that my default mode is
physical books more often.
And here's my theory for
why that is the case.
I think that physical
books have a feature--
and I think it's
important to call it
a feature it is like it
should be compared to software
like bullet point
by bullet point.
I really do think we should
think about it that way.
And this is the feature.
They don't disappear.
I'm thinking of the books
that I buy for my Kindle.
And I often buy things
kind of aspirationally
or speculatively.
I'm like, I'll
read that one day.
That looks good.
And it's there and
it kind of hangs out.
But then, of course,
it gets push down.
And once a book is past
that first page on any
of these devices,
it's basically gone.
I mean, it might as
well be invisible.
Because you just don't sit
down and scroll through and try
to remember that stuff.
Digital books are very
quiet in that way.
They go they go quietly.
They don't even protest.
They're like, what about me?
Oh.
Never seen or heard from again.
Physical books have
this wonderful feature.
They impose themselves.
They have this ability
to literally stand up
for themselves and just take
up a little bit of space
in the real world and sit on a
shelf or in a pile or whatever
and remind you that they
exist and remind you
that you were
interested in them once.
And it sounds simple,
maybe even simplistic,
but I actually think it's a
very significant advantage,
especially in a time when our
attention is being whipsawed
around and we're constantly
getting distracted by things
and interested in new things
to have this thing that
caught your eye once be able
to just kind of like take up
some space and remind you
of that moment is actually
a hugely valuable feature.
So I like print books more
and more for that reason.
AUDIENCE: Sort of
as social media
becomes bigger and a larger
part of everyone's life,
I feel that it's also becoming
a larger part of creators' lives
like writers, television
writers, book writers, things
like that.
When you're writing
a book or when
you're in your
creative process, you
maintain a high availability or
a high degree of availability
for your fans, right?
So do you think that
influences your writing at all?
And beyond just you, do you
see that having an impact
on literature as a whole
for people that are still
out there writing novels?
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
Yeah, that's a good question.
Wow.
That was a really good question.
I think that the
most honest answer
is kind of the less
satisfying one which
is that it's
complicated, and I think
it really depends on the writer.
And all I mean by
that is people often
talk about engaging
with social media
as if it was one thing,
like a binary switch.
You either do it or you don't.
When, of course, it's
a whole spectrum.
I consider myself a
pretty serious user
of Twitter and all this stuff.
There are people who just like
make me look like a luddite.
Make me look like I'm like
taking my horse drawn carriage
to and from the post
office in the next state
because they're just on
it and they're so intense.
And they're just having
these conversations,
they're responding
to everything.
They're inviting these
conversations every day.
And so there's that end of
the spectrum, which I think
has its own pleasures and can
be productive in certain ways.
And then there's other
ends of the spectrum.
Like I think of a few writers
who I really admire who,
there's one in particular.
He's not a fiction writer.
He's a writer of nonfiction, a
critic, and essayist name Sam
Anderson.
And his whole social
media strategy
that he just tweets
once a day and he
tweets the best sentence
he read that day.
It's really cool.
And of course, his
sentences are all fantastic.
You go an follow up on them.
This is going to sound not
the way I want to sound
but it's perfect for
his personal brand.
It is.
It's like the most Sam Anderson
thing you could possibly
do, to put the focus
on great sentences
and just leave it at that.
So anyways, that's a very long
way of saying that I think it's
going to influence everyone's
life and work differently.
And that's a good thing.
If it was one uniform
effect, I think
that would be quite boring.
I do think that when people
think about it influencing
the work itself it definitely
can, of course it can.
Every input changes
what you produce.
I do think that, man, when you
sit down to write something
long and spend day after day
after day alone at your kitchen
table with the internet off,
I really think like to sustain
that, it's got to come
from somewhere inside
and that's always
going to be there,
even if there are these
other little inputs,
these other things that are
coming from email and Twitter
and the web and Facebook and
Google+ and everything else.
I really do think that
the largest part of it
is always going to be internal
because if you don't have that,
then you wouldn't be
sitting there at all.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask
you a little bit about when
you knew that you had
a book in front of you,
when you were like, OK,
I'm going to quit my job
and focus on this full-time, or
did you do it before when you
said I have this idea and I
think I'm going to make it big?
And what that process was
when at the point you said,
I have something.
ROBIN SLOAN: That's
a great question.
Yeah, I'll tell you
what happened to me.
It was a few things
that were my own doing
and also some other things
that kind of happened to me
or I got an assist
from other people.
The story itself, the
seed of the story,
was actually a short story
that I published online years
ago back in 2009.
It was also called "Mr.
Penumbra's 24-Hour Bookstore".
And it started in the same way,
and then it just kind of ended.
It was like there's
a 24-hour bookstore.
That's interesting, the end.
[LAUGHTER]
There was a little
more to it than that.
But it was very
short, and I didn't
think there was going to
be anything more to it.
I thought that was just one
in a series of short stories
I'd been writing and publishing.
So there's a little bit
of short sightedness there
and a bit of failure
on my own part
to maybe recognize what I had.
Because the response
to it was actually
quite a bit more significant
than to anything else
I had written to date.
And in fact, greater than
things I wrote even after that.
I continue to publish
these little short stories.
And they did fine, but
nothing got the same sort
of just strong sudden
enthusiastic response
that this one did.
It took someone else
to tell me that.
It was an agent that I ended
up getting in touch with
and really hitting it off with.
And it was actually her counsel.
She said, you know, that
story is really good
and there might be a
bigger story there.
And I had not really considered
that until that moment.
But as soon as she
said it, it seemed
like it was probably right.
So that was still in the
realm of speculation.
I had a short seed of a story
that had been almost like
a prototype and it had been
validated a little bit in a way
that some others hadn't.
And I now had the notion that
it could be a full length novel,
but I didn't know exactly
what to do with that notion.
I did have a full-time
job at the time.
I would not have contemplated
leaving my job just
to try to write this
because at that time,
I had no evidence that I could
actually finish a full length
novel.
I had never written
anything that long.
I wasn't one of
those people that
had three drafts in
a drawer that they
had sort of written to practice.
So I just worked nights
and weekends and holidays
and basically wherever
I could fit it
in while I was
working full-time.
And I emerged at the
end of about a year
of that kind of work with
a draft, a first draft.
And that's what I sent
back to this agent.
And said, hey,
what do you think?
You said this could be a
full length novel, right?
And we started talking about
it and editing it and making
it better.
And from that point, the
process was, in many ways,
pretty traditional.
It was drafts and
sending it to publishers,
and finding a
publisher who liked it,
and et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
And it was after that, after
I sold it, that I left my job.
But I would say that the two
important pieces-- the really
important piece--
were one, having
a sense that I had the seed
of something that was good
and that there were some
validation associated
with that.
But the fact that it had
been a short story first
and that this very smart
person said like trust
me I've published a
lot of books and I
think there's something here.
And then the other
thing was just
being willing to do the work.
I was no fun for that year.
I didn't go anywhere
or really see anyone
or form any additional human
relationships or anything.
But that's how I did it.
AUDIENCE: So I read
the short story
about three or four years ago--
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --I loved it.
I thought it was amazing.
I didn't even know
you made a book out
of it until I saw your name
of the Authors calendar.
ROBIN SLOAN: Ha!
AUDIENCE: But I'm
glad you're here.
And I'm glad I get
to read the book.
So something I really liked
about the short story,
so this question
might be irrelevant
if people haven't read
it, but the protagonist,
he never actually says
anything in quotes.
Like he always
kind of says stuff,
but it's never a direct quote.
And I really, really
love that style.
And when I thumbed
through the book,
I noticed he
actually says stuff.
So I'm kind of curious, was
that on purpose the first time?
And how did you
transition into doing
it the other way
for a full book?
ROBIN SLOAN: That is such
a perceptive question.
That's like you're
in the inner circle.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like I said,
I loved the short story.
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
No, that's fantastic.
No, you're absolutely right.
You're right.
This will be interesting to
no one else in this room,
but I'm totally OK with that.
It was an intentional
stylistic choice.
As both a reader and a
writer, I have sometimes
found dialogue, especially
very functional dialogue,
like what do you think, I
don't know, OK, let's go,
to just be sort of
like boring to read
and certainly boring to write.
That has a lot to say
about my own skill
level and my own development
as a writer as much as anything
else, but I definitely
had that in my head
when I started writing
the short story.
And so yes, it was
very intentional.
I wanted you to
never quite be sure
whether he was thinking
something or saying it out
loud because I think
sometimes we're not sure
if we're thinking something
or saying it out loud.
And I actually
think that there's
an interesting sort
of malleability,
like the membrane
between those two things
is actually thinner
than we sometimes think,
or fiction would
lead us to believe.
So that was the
effect I intended.
And some people hated
it, for the record.
I really liked it too.
But for the book, I
still kept some of that,
but especially reading
it at book length
and knowing that the reaction
in some cases had been negative
or at least people had
expressed confusion,
I didn't want to go with that
style for the whole book.
So I guess you could say
I capitulated to fiction
standards and put a few
of his obviously stated
words in quotes.
But there's still plenty
of the little things that
exist in that gray area
between internal monologue
and dialogue.
Good to know.
Good data point
because I like it too.
Maybe if I find enough
people like you,
maybe I'll be
brave enough to try
to write another whole
story with that style.
AUDIENCE: So one quick
question and one longer one.
Where do we find
the short story?
Is it available online?
ROBIN SLOAN: It is
available online.
It is free.
You can buy it,
of course, if you
want to have it on your
Kindle or just send me $3,
but it's free.
It's on my website.
I'm RobinSloan.com.
And it'll be there forever.
AUDIENCE: Great.
And the longer
question is, I'm not
sure I should mention the
surprise that I got when
I first was reading the book
and turned off the light,
but could you say a little
bit about how that happened?
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I spent
some time looking
to see if there was
a message there.
And I seemed to have
missed it if there was.
ROBIN SLOAN: Yeah.
And since you
asked, I have often
debated whether to
reveal this or not.
I'll just go ahead and
reveal it because maybe it
will help sell some books.
MALE SPEAKER: Spoiler alert.
ROBIN SLOAN: The spoiler alert.
The cover glows in the
dark which is pretty cool.
And many people purchase
the book not knowing that.
And truly, I've gotten
some emails sent,
I think, late at night.
These are very
contemporaneous reports
as people type I just
woke up because I
had to go to the bathroom
and something was glowing
and it was your book.
So I can't take
any credit for it.
It was the design team at
Farrar, Straus, and Giroux,
the original publisher.
In particular, the cover
designer Rodrigo Corral,
who's one of the
great book jacket
designers working right now.
And yeah, they pitched me the
idea and I told them like,
are you kidding?
That sounds fantastic.
You do not have to twist my arm.
It has.
It's been a fun surprise
for a lot of people.
And what was the other
part of your question?
AUDIENCE: Well, is
there a message?
ROBIN SLOAN: Oh,
is there a message?
Because of course,
there's a pattern
of sort of a geometric slightly
abstracted pattern of books
on the cover.
The answer is I don't think so.
If there is, I'm
not aware of it.
I will, to be totally candid,
about two or three months
after the book came
out, it occurred
to me for the first time,
wait a minute, what is they
put a code in there?
What is they put a code
and I don't know about it?
I've got to know if
there's a code on my book!
So I did the same thing.
I kind of like counted them up.
I could not devive
any meaning either.
So if there's a code,
it is cunning indeed.
AUDIENCE: I'm
relieved to hear that.
I spent some time [INAUDIBLE].
ROBIN SLOAN: And it is also
not a code of my own design.
So see Rodrigo
Corral, code master.
MALE SPEAKER: We've
had sort of questions
about your characters and
your stylistic choices.
One of the questions
I have for you
is tell us a little bit
about your writing style.
I mean, do you start
with a detailed outline?
Or do you kind of let the
story go where it will?
ROBIN SLOAN: You know,
a little bit of both.
I feel like all my answers
are a little bit of both.
It's complicated.
But it's true.
And I do start with a
sense of what I'm doing.
I'm not one of those people who
sets up a couple of characters
or a situation and then just
says we'll see what happens.
Part of the fun of writing
is finding out as you go.
There is some of
that, of course.
You don't have everything
kind of plotted out
like a schematic or a blueprint.
But certainly
writing this book, I
did have some sense of
what the puzzles were,
what the great kind of puzzle
is lurking behind the scenes
or going to be.
More than anything else
though, I tell you,
I feel like the
thing that is really
the most central
part of my process
is neither of those things.
It's not the organic kind
of following the characters.
And it's also not that
the schematic outline.
It's something else.
I actually don't know if this is
particularly productive or not,
but it's my notes.
I'm a diligent
note taker anytime
I run into anything
weird or interesting
or something that just
sticks in my brain,
you know some things just kind
of seem to adhere somehow.
It could be the
name of a street.
You know, you're driving,
you see a street sign,
or it can be something you
overhear in a coffee shop
or whatever.
I write all those things down.
And then I end up typing
them into the computer.
And when I write, I almost
always have that open
and I'm just kind of swimming
in this soup of weird old stuff,
things that caught my eye
at one point or another.
And often it's almost
like building with LEGOs.
I don't know if you
ever played with LEGOs
but I remember being a kid--
MALE SPEAKER: Too much.
ROBIN SLOAN: --yeah, I remember
being a kid-- and part of it
is-- actually, I never
thought of this metaphor
before but it's
actually quite accurate.
You want to design something.
You want to build
something with your LEGOs,
but then you're scraping through
and you're kind of like, oh,
that's such an awesome piece.
And you find a way to make
it part of the creation.
And so for me, writing is a
lot like playing with LEGOs.
MALE SPEAKER: Like those little
neon antennas from the sci-fi--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And the--
MALE SPEAKER: Is that
in the pirate set?
ROBIN SLOAN: It was.
It was all the space pieces.
It was all the
glowy space pieces.
Yes.
So a novel for me is an excuse
to use all the glowy space
pieces.
Yeah.
That's right.
MALE SPEAKER: So can
you tell us a little bit
about maybe your
next writing project,
what you have coming up?
ROBIN SLOAN: Sure.
Well it's a two part answer.
The one that is
right now, the one
that's kind of the newest
thing is a short story prequel
to the novel.
It's called "Ajax
Penumbra 1969".
It takes place in 1969.
And it is about
how this man, who
would become Mr.
Penumbra, how he arrived
in San Francisco, why he came
here, what made him stay,
and what he saw along the way.
And there's a lot
of fun period stuff,
especially for people who knew
the Bay Area and San Francisco.
It's, I think, a lot of
things that will make you
smile and just maybe people
will learn a few things too
about the origins of BART and
the origins of the internet
and the stuff buried beneath
the city of San Francisco.
It's actually pretty crazy.
So that's out right now.
And it's available online.
And I know we have
physical copies here
for folks in the room.
And I'm working on another novel
as well-- another full length
novel that is nothing to do
with bookstores, unfortunately.
Nothing to do with the
world of Mr. Penumbra,
but it's a California book.
The story begins
in the Bay Area.
There's a lot of technology
in it, although sort
of a different
kind of technology.
And this book is going to
have a lot of food in it.
AUDIENCE: Going back to the
previous question about sort
of your writing process,
one of the things I really
liked when I read
the book was how
you incorporated a lot
of real world information
and events and books into it.
And I was wondering
how that factored in
as you were writing.
ROBIN SLOAN: Sure.
That's a good question.
There's two parts there.
There's the books and
there's all the other stuff.
And I have to say, writing
a book about a bookstore
is like ultimate
license to just stock it
with all your favorites.
So any title or author
mentioned in this novel
is it's one of my
favorite books.
And you can just interpret
all of those mentions as me
kind of saying I bow
down to the masters
and paying homage to
the stuff that I've
read that just really
made a difference
and made me want to
write in the first place.
So there's that piece of it.
The other piece--
the sort of the bits
of our world, whether it's bits
of software or real companies
like Google or
real ideas that are
very much kind of in
the air right now--
it relates to some
of the things we've
already talked about
such as the fact
that these things always seem
present to me and very much
part of the world.
But I wasn't seeing them
on the page of novels
and I wanted to remedy that.
I guess maybe the most
accurate way to answer
is that I, as a reader,
I read a lot of novels--
contemporary novels, a
lot of science fiction--
and I have always appreciated
the kind of novels that
seem to just like
grab the Zeitgeist
and crystallize the moment
that we're in right now.
I think of William
Gibson as being
a writer who does
this really well.
And Neal Stephenson when
he decides he wants to
is also great at it.
There are plenty more.
But I love that.
I just love the feeling
of reading a novel.
And It's almost like it's a
lens and the world is getting
kind of collected and probably
distorted it a little bit.
But then beamed right
into your brain.
I just think it's one of the
wonderful functions of fiction.
So I guess I wanted to do that.
They're my favorite
kind of books.
So why not try to write
your favorite kind of book?
And also, some of it
was just inescapable
at-- to give you a
concrete example,
when I worked at
Twitter, I dabbled
a little bit with
a software platform
called Hadoop-- this thing for
sort of big data analytics.
I know Google has its
own version of it,
or it is a version
of something actually
that Google kind of originated.
But using it was so, to me,
striking and interesting,
and literally kind of creates
these strange new feelings
like unfamiliar feelings.
It felt very
oracular to me to be
able to kind of like
ask these questions
of this vast database.
And so having done that and
having a fiction writer's
brain, literally, this
could have been a novel
about like an 18th
century whaling family.
And somehow, Hadoop
would have been in it.
I don't know how that
would have worked.
But there are these things
that-- it goes back to the note
thing-- they just
sticking in your craw.
And they're just kind of
like glued into your brain.
And yeah, so that happens too.
MALE SPEAKER: What got
glued into your brain
that kicked off the
Mr. Penumbra storyline?
ROBIN SLOAN: Well I mean,
here's the honest answer.
I wish it was way
more epic than this.
I wish it was that I'd like
wandered into some spooky
bookstore somewhere and then
the next day it was gone.
In fact, it was a tweet.
It was not even my own tweet.
It was a tweet sent by a
friend of mine years ago,
back in late 2008.
I remember very vividly exactly
where I was when I read it.
I was walking down California
Street near my neighborhood
out in the Richmond
in San Francisco.
And her tweet said, just misread
a sign for 24-hour book drop
as 24-hour bookshop.
My disappointment
is beyond words.
Which seemed very
reasonable to me.
I would have been
disappointed as well.
And I don't know, it
just made me laugh.
It made me think about
24-hour bookstores
and what a terrible
and wonderful idea
a 24-hour bookstore would be.
And more than anything else,
it just stuck in that way
we've been talking about.
And so I copied it down,
paste it into my notes
file, which got transmitted
back to the big sort
of central repository
on my computer.
And a few months later
when I was sitting down
to start a new short story,
I saw it there near the top.
And it just seemed clear to
me that something interesting
would happen in a
24-hour bookstore.
But if not for that
tweet, in late 2008,
it would have been 18th
century whalers all the way.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I really
like the book.
And what were some of
your favorite books?
ROBIN SLOAN: Oh, that's the
hardest question of all.
That's terrible.
What a burdensome question.
There's too many to list.
I will say, so I have to
split my sort of response
into two streams.
One is because this novel
is very much a quest,
and of course, it
itself pays homage
to every YA fantasy series
with dragons or elves in it.
Of course, those are still
some of my favorites.
I don't know if people have
read "The Chronicles of Prydain"
by Lloyd Alexander.
Still love those. "The Dark
Is Rising" by Susan Cooper.
Slightly, slightly
less well known,
but I think a nearly perfect
YA sort of fantasy series.
"The Dragonlance
Chronicles" by Margaret Weis
and Tracy Hickman.
There's a character in the novel
who met his best friend back
in sixth grade
because he spied him
reading this book
across the room.
And I have a friend who
I've known since sixth grade
because I spied him reading
"The Dragonlance Chronicles"
across the room and I was like,
we should probably be friends.
On the other side,
though, there's
a lot of science
fiction that I love.
The stuff that I find myself
responding to most strongly
right now, like
really at this moment,
is stuff that is sort of
science fiction and sort
of not, stuff that maybe blurs
the boundary between science
fiction and literary fiction.
And there's a
writer, just to name
one-- I could go on and
on-- but to pick one,
there's a writer named M.
John Harrison who's British.
He's been writing
for a long time.
But his latest books
form a trilogy-- sort
of a loose trilogy.
The first one's called "Light".
One's called "Nova Swing".
The third is called
"Empty Space".
And I mean, I think they belong
on the literary fiction shelf.
But at the same time, they're
spaceships and quantum physics
and weird adventures
in lost nebulaes.
And it's fantastic stuff.
It's just like truly,
truly awesome writing.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of trilogies,
the sort of goes
to do authors feel
an obligation to their readers.
After I read the book, and I
read it maybe six months ago,
I went to Amazon
to read reviews,
which is always kind of fun.
And one common thread seemed to
be, gosh, I wish it was longer
or gosh I can't wait until
the next one comes out.
So the prequel is a delight.
But like when one
comment I remember is
people are going gosh,
what happened with Kat?
What happened to
the relationship
between Kat and
the main character?
Do you have any interest or do
you feel any quotes obligation
towards your readers
to finish that story?
ROBIN SLOAN: That's such
an interesting question.
It's actually a huge question
and weighs so much more
on other frankly far more
successful and established
writers than me.
I think when you're just
starting out, happily,
there's just not that
many people reading yet.
And so maybe not that
sense of gravity.
I think of stories I've heard
of George RR Martin's fans.
Whenever he does anything
like he watches a football
or like writes an episode of
the TV show, they're like,
what do you think you're doing?
Get back to work.
Which is just wrong
in so many ways.
I don't know.
I don't know if I have
a good answer to that
as I don't think I've
experienced that yet myself.
And it would, obviously, be a
privilege to experience that.
I think you have to meet
people halfway though.
Nobody wants writers,
readers most of all
don't want writers to just be
story making machines, kind
of responding to every little
kind of whim and preference.
It's robotic and it's boring.
And it doesn't produce the
work that paradoxically
inspires that kind of devotion.
So there has to be
some independence
and some sense of
I'm a do my thing.
But on the other
hand, I also don't
believe in locking
yourself away.
Let me put it this way.
If I get enough emails from
people clamoring for more, then
maybe I'll consider it.
I've only gotten a few so far.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for joining us, Robin.
ROBIN SLOAN: Thank you so
much for your [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]